hallo herzlich willkommen auf einem
kanal verleast und ich bin hier heute in
mannheim auf dem maimarkt stehe hier
gerade vor dem haupteingang und ich
werde heute jetzt diese messe für euch
besuchen und werde euch einfach mal
mitnehmen
ich gehe generell ganz gern auf messen
und das hier ist von der messe für alles
also hier gibt's was um ihn herum küche
haushalt motor autos wohnungsbau hausbau
garten also eigentlich so ziemlich alles
hier hat insgesamt über 1400 aussteller
und ich werde jetzt einfach mal ein paar
zeigen die mich interessieren die
vielleicht euch interessieren könnten
und deswegen gehen wird einfach zusammen
rein
hier seht ihr einfach mal so ein paar
gartenausstellung
hier bauen renovieren energie das machen
wir sollten recht
erst da gibt es einfach so verschiedene
hallen mit verschiedenen themen und hier
beispielsweise auch bauen renovieren
energie und trifft ihr zum beispiel
einen rollrasen den musste ich schon
verlegt es geht nämlich sehr einfach
und er wächst immer sucht die treffer
wirklich über jahre hinweg kein unkraut
durchweg bis verlegen gibt so einfach
viel einfacher als laminat oder parkett
und ja wissen müsste dass ich auch eine
coole idee für die terrasse oder für den
garten
dann holen wir wachsen und dass ich
jetzt meine hallo hier bin ich genau
richtig jetzt alles rund um den haushalt
und da gehen max zusammen rein
ich stehe hier vor dem der camper
tiefstand uns lag im ziel seinen zauber
stein dem jetzt bald bekommen habe ich
mir schon bestellt war vor drei tagen
schon mal hier und ich zeige dir ein
paar produkte und schaue mir diese
vorführung an und hat ihr stehen bleibt
dabei sei also dass ich die maschine der
ein oder andere kennt sie vielleicht in
die maschine habe auch einen youtube
channel der heiße leckeren macina dass
ihr song ist auf jeden fall mal
vorbeischauen und zurzeit mir jetzt wie
man das mit diesem stein bargeld das sie
jetzt sauber stein problematik
dieser stein ist nur einen stein aus 100
prozent natur tun
ok und dem aus dem backofen aus dem ganz
normalen bank ist ein steifer als alle
produkte die wir darauf
und in zukunft
konstanz
die farbe von einem stein finde ich
super das ist natürlich ein stein den
hierauf da müssen jetzt schon 7
mal was
in der beliebten und draußen im meer der
beziehung zur setzte auf eine partie
ganz blass und wenn ihr mal platz musste
auch nicht mehr ok also eine natürliche
antihaftbeschichtung richtig gedacht
okay super vorbereitet
der teig wird dann einfach mit so einem
teig mädchen auf dem stein fixiert also
ausgerollt und ich sehe auch dass der da
einfach drauf haften bleibt ohne dass
jetzt mail oder fett benutzt dann kommt
da diese schwarz creme drauf und dann
kann der flammkuchen mit allem möglichen
gelegt werden
wir machen jetzt eine vegetarische
variante und eine variante mit speck
was kann man denn noch so auf dem zauber
steinbach
und noch etwas ich glaube das
schwierigste wird sowieso das warten
aber wir haben auch gleich ein stückchen
näher
es wird ja alles weggegessen
mal auf
ohne später kameramann ist aber mein
name ist gesorgt
aber nachdem wichtig so schmeckt
wirklich super schön lecker und ich
zeige mich daheim noch ein paar anderen
oberlichte produkte
dank martina ich habe sehr viel spaß
ich bin die am schönsten stand auf dem
maimarkt denn dieser stand ist der
einzige deinen pinkfarbenen teppich
neben mir steht der verzauberte markt
und der kopf blume von gleich drei
ab
ich hab schon auf der ambiente in
frankfurt kennen gelernt und heute hab
ich mir besucher schauen wir mal die
ganzen produkte mit dem an
erfolge steht die mutter von daniela
katzenberger wir machen kein foto medias
ist allein wann genau so wie hier sehen
wir eine richtig große farbauswahl
diesen fahrplan sollen wir haben
insgesamt von jedem produkt 10 oder 11
auf ok kann einige fans schon zu hause
zweitens man nicht gerade eben sagen ich
zeig dir einfach was ich glaube ich
müsste mir ja sowieso dich ja was wir
hier haben eigentlich eins unserer
neuesten produkte das ist im topflappen
und untersetzer es ist alles aus silikon
300 rate zu beständig zwischen maschinen
fest oder ganz so richtig knallen heiße
töpfe drauf student vom her darunter
auch gleichzeitig als topflappen
verwenden und immer nach getaner arbeit
aber in die spur
rapid
ansonsten haben wir hier eine mega
auswahl an verschiedenen ländern löffeln
suppenkelle alters und auch hier ist
ganz wichtig dass das immer aus silikon
das heißt also jeder der das benutzt
kann das bis 300 grad in der heißen
sonne lieben das
heise edelstahl könne weißt du warum
damit das ganze stabil ist also auch
wenn du jetzt schwere sachen zum
beispiel aus der pfanne nehmen möchte
das heißt dass auch wenn du mal eine
homo fahne hast kannst du wirklich ihnen
die hohe fahne reingehen und wenn ich
das los dass jeder in seine position
die zeit dass es sind eigentlich zwei
wände erstmal irdischer gänge und dann
mit silikon überzogen oder sowas kauft
man einmal benutzt sein leben
dreimal in der richtigen farbe
pölten
so zeigt es wird einfach ein paar coole
kisten gegenstände oder scharfe messer
ja die habe ich ja schon wie sind carbon
stahl wohl gemerkt hast deine damit
schneidet sie sind wirklich forscher das
heißt dass er egal ob ich jetzt zu hause
zum beispiel tomaten schneiden
ob ich schneide ob ich muss schneide ob
ich zwiebelschneiden funktioniert
optimal aber der richtige brunner ist
dieses brett und zwar kannst du damit
wenn du jetzt deine sachen schnitten
hast einfach einmal an den tasten an
diesen zusammendrücken jetzt denkst du
das ganze alles was zugeschnittener
faust i quasi in eine schüssel nicht
mehr daneben denkmal wenn du zum
beispiel jetzt das video geschnitten
vertont
das ist motto wenn du das dann auch sehr
an für drauf mit dem brit nicht mehr
passiert und auch da ganz wichtig drei
jahre garantie das heißt also dieser
klappmechanismus die sich als stabil
ganz ganz wichtig da natürlich auch
spülmaschine
zu machen habe ich ja schon daheim sagt
er schon einmal gesehen und es gibt auch
bald
aber eigentlich ist er bekannt für die
kommenden monate ganz genau das war
sozusagen unser produkt und zwar erstens
wenn es so ist dass es überhaupt möglich
nicht passieren ich mache das möglich
ist egal war das witzige ist du legst
das einfach auf den topf frau im moment
egal welchen topf doors das 1
wenn der kopf muss also wenn ihr an der
seite seines
ich denke ich es eigentlich darf vorteil
nummer eins
deckel drauf in dem augenblick wo das
über wochen mit stücken lässt sich diese
kleinen bunten blätter das heißt es gibt
einfach nach oben auf
und all das was wir normalerweise
entlang läuft
der absolute hammer produkt warum
einfach cool aussieht als gut aussieht
und vor allem jeder kennt das problem
ein nudelsieb immer wahnsinnig viel
platz in münchen sprachen schon mal
aufgefallen
hier hast du das ganz klein im
küchenschrank und wenn du brauchst
einmal und dann ist das draußen das bis
300 grad im topf tun das heißt du
könntest eine kartoffeln kochen seine
frühstückseier satz zähne und dann
nimmst du einfach an den griffen die
nämlich kalt werden
kennst du das einfach aus sich
herausgehen das wirklich sehr sehr
simpel und das schöne ist dabei für den
murat habe ich extra einbauen lassen
etwas kleinere portion schießen
spaß beiseite dieses ganz kleine junior
sie war extra dafür machen lassen
fast genau eine pose
oder fünf riesen-chancen schrank das
natürlich
jetzt zeigte markus oft die besten
möglichen utensilien hatte ich find's
super vor allen dingen weil du jeder
kennt das problem nur du hast noch
belasten angeschnitten mit zitrone was
machst du alufolie zellophan papier
extremsten stretcher wings den sexy
einmal auf die größe wie du brauchst ist
vorne einfach über die zwiebel drüber
das ganze ist luftdicht verpackt um die
speiseplan länger frisch der brüller ist
du kannst du sitzt natürlich auch bei
allen offenen bechern mal das heißt wenn
du zum beispiel zuhause meine butter
milch sahne oder solche sana einmal
drüber ziehen jetzt ist das ganze
nämlich zu das ist wirklich dicht und es
läuft ja auch nicht mehr raus was sowohl
ist ganz oft einsetzen wenn du deinen
koffer packen um den urlaub geht jetzt
das problem wenn dir dann der cockpit
rings motto dass das flugzeug aus
sollten einfach vorne darüber kann die
absolut nichts mehr passieren und
geniale produkt ist natürlich auch in
verschiedenen farben und auch in
verschiedenen größen
und neben mir steht die frau bei der
alles angefangen hat letztes jahr das
ist die angie die richtige kitsch made
to sally hay angie einig dass du da bist
ständig und als ich dich was du tust
dann ja ich kann mich nur immer wenn ich
mir deine videos eingebaut
klar bei der angel haben eine
kitchenette gekauft das er noch mal
schöne himbeereis fahrer
heute zeigt sie mir ein ganz anderes
gerät wollte sich noch nicht zu hause
habe aber wenn sie heute gefällt dann
muss es wird zeit im moment zum beispiel
ist ja so ein bisschen so ein wetter
sommer heiß mag alt da braucht man immer
vitaminen und ich mache mir morgens
immer meine grün smoothies oder meines
mich also vitamin shakes und es dafür
braucht man so nichts und jetzt habe ich
hier zum beispiel irgendwann das ist
total gut reinigen und einzelfall
zurückgehen und man kriegt auch kaum
erkältung wenn man immer irgendwie also
zu sich nimmt und das kann man ja ganz
einfach reinschmeißen man braucht nicht
mal sehen was man einen obsttag schmeißt
man mit dazu schaffen ist nur noch über
glöckchen dann im einsatz man kann dazu
auch ein wasser nehmen das ganze auf
weil wir trinken wollen
apfelsaft und wann william parker
freunden lernt die kommen rein es ist
auch sehr lecker aus glaubt es wird
jetzt wär doch cool mit schirmen könnte
noch an kokain tot also irgendwas was
man dann frühstück und jetzt ist es
sowohl bei diesen mixa werden um so nice
price funktion ja also normalerweise
kannst du es noch länger laufen lassen
aber wir probieren weil ich glaube das
ist eigentlich auch jetzt schon ganze
sieht richtig trieben
der kameramann immer zu ändern muss ist
unsere vorkoster
wollen ja jetzt zeigst du uns noch das
schöne waffeleis mein mann ich zwei
moment noch ein bisschen zugleich sich
das leisten
aber ich glaube jetzt gleich das
probiert dann krieg ich das auch mit
nach hause
belgischen waffeln essen so viel sahne
und kirschen obendrauf zu sehr schön
große löcher in dieser zeit ja den habe
ich auch
also der müssen besonders ich habe mich
navarra
hat das recht gut
jo
jetzt
schmutz und das bild der rabatte stellen
und wenn man die auf dem gitter aus
dann gibt es von beiden seiten wenn es
auf dem teller systems während das neue
spitze
jetzt kommen noch ein bisschen puder
zusammen mit fox ab ohne drauf
turboden verharrt schon ganz plötzlich
zu lecker
mindmeister naja
wollte
das ist ein richtig erwacht ist lecker
ok wenn keiner will muss ich aber noch
ganzes jahr nicht
ja aber schön vorsichtig aber er war
super ein sehr wenn man sie einmal den
schlüssel vom band ist zu spät
hinauf passiert
ich glaube das war nicht unser letztes
zusammen ganzen würde mich freuen wenn
er mal richtig zusammen war behörden wer
bei uns zu machen
eine neue küche gezogen denk ich mir mit
pinkfarben der spitze mit das war ein
die von kitchenaid stand
die sie jetzt mal einen kleinen roboter
hinaus ist ein kleines haustier
und ich überlege ich mir auch so ein
holweide
der high line park hatch und das ist
eine ganz gute unterstützung für zuhause
da kann er einfach so um sorgen was
anderes arbeitet
letztes jahr wurden an einen ganz
deutschland 60.000 roboter verkauft die
nicht von mir sondern auch von anderen
herstellern und ja vielleicht ein oder
anderen schon einfach oder mit
vielleicht könnt ihr mir empfehlen habt
ihr vielleicht eine bestimmte marke
ich mich total freuen wenn ihr mir sagen
können ob wir vielleicht auch so einen
bauch- oder hat oder hatte
seid ihr zufrieden damit nicht zufrieden
mit welchem hersteller könnt ihr mir
empfehlen denn da bin ich wirklich
andere überlegung ist so einen hinzu
der hitze auf dem ich viele qualitäts-
und preisunterschiede gibt die schon 420
euro aber auch für 1000 euro
diese kleine katze dass die keine haare
verlieren haare aufsammelt
zu müssen
lieberberg mit
wir verraten staubsauger sind auch
bereit und vorwerk er sieht etwas anders
aus
aus diesem thema
das letzte aus uns
sinkt der woche streifen unterschied das
hat ja einer von euch den da und hier
habe ich jetzt noch ein ganz tolles
schneidegerät für euch entdeckt und zwar
ist es so ähnlich
der meister nur finde ich dieses gerät
viel praktischer mit den verschiedenen
aufsätzen aber das würde ich euch dann
einfach in einem anderen video mal
zeigen ich hab jetzt nämlich bestellt
und es auch zu hause und wenn es dann
für euch ausprobieren
hier waren wir dann noch in indien essen
und es war dann auch praktisch der
abschluss von unserer maimarkt uhr
so ich bin jetzt wieder draußen ich
hoffe ich konnte euch hier so ein paar
einblicke zeigen ein paar neue produkte
paar stände und falls sie noch fragen
habt könnt ihr gerne in den kommentaren
stellen
ich bin wirklich total ko ich bin froh
dass wir nach hause fahren
und ja ich freue mich über einen
kommentar von euch wenn ihr möchtet ihr
euch gerne öfter mal auf menschen
mitnehmen sagt mir auch bescheid
ich finde mich wirklich total der messe
feiern ich schaue mir gerne alles an
probiere gern neues aus wird der neues
und bevor ich es vergesse lassen auf
jeden fall einen kommentar wegen diesem
saugroboter fans ihr da eben in die
erfahrungen schon habt positiv negativ
bald ist wichtig und da freut sich auf
jeden fall drauf und bin sehr gespannt
was ihr zu berichten habt ich gehe ins
auto mein mann fährt staffel runde
schlafen